[Applause]
I that was I know I know from our last
interview that you're a great singer but
that is awesome I loved your whole song
well you know desperate times right
those are just regular great times well
the show's been on the air
20 years and so
um that's the year that you won I was
gonna say 20 years you are
perfect because I used to wear this pink
ring every time you sang and I was
pretty sure it was you 20 years ago
that's longevity is hard in this career
it's super weird I mean Dirty Jobs has
been on 20 Deadliest Catch has been on
19. so
um you know I think in this in this
industry everybody's you know you look
for hits and you look for what's new and
uh the thing I was really fortunate to
stumble across were shows that had big
themes under them so it's all kind of
the same it's just me tapping the
country on the shoulder every week
saying what about her what about him get
a load of that which is so cool and
people still watch it's unbelievable
yeah I mean I'm castrating cats on
International television and people are
watching of course we are why would we
not why yeah I had a ball
oh
nice that was really good wait have
y'all ever met Joey bellerman okay no
but I feel like I've known you for like
two minutes
a solid five minutes
um so wait did you did you ever get in a
scary situation with dirty jobs where
you were like ah this is too far only
every day for 20 years yeah okay I mean
my my job on that show I mean if you
haven't seen it is is to essentially
assume the identity of an apprentice so
it's Groundhog's Day for me every day
you know it's the first day on the job
so what's like the scariest though well
if you got a thing for Heights you
probably don't want to be on top of the
Mackinac Bridge or a radio tower
I don't mind Heights but I still don't
want to do it if you have if you have a
thing for tight places you probably
don't want to opal mine you probably
don't want to be you know in some of
these crazy jammed up places a mile
below the Earth's surface nope so it's a
it's you never know what you're going to
get on the show except for an honest
look at work right why are they laughing
oh okay
no but it's true so so like you were
talking about jumping out of a plane
right so it's I mean that's a great
example I jumped out of a plane with the
golden knights who were essentially the
uh the sort of the Blue Angels of the
army I've done the Blue Angel thing yeah
trained paratroopers and yeah the first
time you go out and pull your own shoot
is a moment that you're never ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever gonna forget or
never ever ever ever have yeah yeah it
makes an impression you know but but
that's the point of the show it's not
it's not to be an adrenaline junkie it's
just to show people look these are the
people who are building our world
they're tending to our civilization this
is what they do every single day now
I've done it for 20 years but you know
in the end I go home I take a shower I
come I do your show I sing Deck the
Halls and get on with my life this is
there every day this is the world we
live in and without these folks
party's over right plumbers steam
Fitters pipefitters I think we all
figured that out during covet when
nobody can come right now yeah well
that's why Dirty Jobs came back you know
essential work suddenly became headline
news and now everybody's talking about
the definition of what it means to have
a an essential job what it means to work
so you know what we took for granted and
what we take for granted every day yeah
agreed oh like indoor plumbing I had to
do a lot of things in a forest I did not
want to do
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]